for this portion I'm going to I'm going
to put the questions to the group and
whichever of the presenters are inclined
to answer they are welcome to to kind of
jump in pass it back and forth and if
anyone says anything that anyone else
would like to also comment on briefly
please feel free to do so let's see
there's one question and I think this
was something that came up in Alec and
Alex talk but anyone could respond to it
could you please say more about the
difference between validation and praise
that you mentioned well it's funny I was
gonna actually comment on the question
that Carla was talking about earlier
between mentalizing and validation and
again I am no expert of mentalizing i
literally just had a two day course but
my sense about mentalizing and
validation is that for the DBT
therapists in the room level one
validation is kind of listening with the
kind of beginner's mind and kind of in
so doing asking clarifying questions to
better understand what that individuals
experiences thoughts feelings and so on
so there's a level one kind of
validation for sure level two validation
DBT is kind of accurate reflection so
you're saying this and do i understand
that correctly right and level 3
validation is this idea of mind reading
which is kind of verbalizing on verbal
eyes experience of the client so I mean
in terms of mentalizing and validation
DBT style my sense would be there's the
overlap between at least levels one and
two then when you get into level four
and five dbt validation level for
validation is based on your past
experience you know it makes sense why
you're having difficulty now right based
on your past history of trauma and we're
abuse was so and so it makes it hard
what to sit in a closed office with with
a with a male therapist for example and
level five validation is it makes sense
base anybody would have the reaction
you're having right now based on
normative functioning so there's
different levels of validation and I
think the greatest overlap between
mentalizing and DBT I in my initial
thought about it is love
one and two well look my reading and and
then three I guess I mentioned here
Carla in terms of in terms of
mentalizing would you kind of hazard a
guess I'm what I'm wondering if you're
feeling angry said absolutely I do you
think you know that would still count as
maintained yes and when you when you
feel talking to the mic moment UK you
can guess what what the person might be
thinking but you will start off with the
level one is able to yes we've to a
level three yes I think that's a really
that's really helpful thank you and in
terms of the difference between
validation reinforcement there are two
completely different things because
validation is acceptance there is
absolutely you know no approval
necessarily there for example if you're
saying you know what gosh I totally
understand why you cut yourself you know
what in the past when you cut just gave
you that release and you just felt
better in a moment of course you'll
continue cut if you had that in anything
that I say was there an approval like
continue cutting great job absolutely
not so validation is acceptance
reinforcement is approval and and that
again you're saying reinforcement that
notion that if someone is using praise
believing that it's that trying to do
validation but doing praise that they
might be trying to do reinforcements
exactly that's one of the things that
trips parents and trips even even
providers in terms of being afraid to
validate because they're afraid that
they're going to somehow ring force you
know whatever negative behavior that's
happening but you could say I really
noticed you put a lot of effort into
that and validate their effort and
behavior and in so doing it feels like
feels like reinforcement it feels like
praise like I really validating
acknowledging that effort so there's
sometimes where it can have a duplicate
of effect would you great not
necessarily
let's do it can you please say it again
so let's say my son was having trouble
with baseball and he finally gets out
there and kind of practices and put some
effort into his practice and I say you
know wow I really noticed you put a lot
of effort into your baseball practicing
today mm-hmm so I'm validating his
effort not as say not not that he
performed well not that you know but I'm
validating effort so he gave a behavior
yes I do want to increase right but this
is this is something that you you're
reinforcing in the moment right now you
know I mean you know I'm seeing that
you're putting a lot of effort into this
um not necessarily saying great job with
that yeah right I'm reinforcing i guess
i would say and I'm acknowledging his
his behavior I'm acknowledging it as is
as it is and so I think that in that
that's an example to me where it could
be both right right well validation in
its most core is understanding it
usually validation is about you know
something that we suffer about and well
usually it can actually be a lot of
things you know in terms of what we are
usually doing is we're validating the
peas they're the patient is suffering
about it can of course be something else
you know I understand how happy you can
be about about this right but this is
this is not something that is
necessarily what else poor methods are
before moving further in or moving on
kid could we clarify Alec you had said
that teachers will do praise thinking
they're validating could you give an
example of that of like a praise that's
clearly not a validation it's a praise
it's like you can do this now at some
level fundamentally I'm validating my
belief I'm validating the belief that
you're capable right but it's more late
doing it more like a cheerleading
encouragement and like oh I'm so I'm so
bad at math oh you can do it you can do
it and that's not validating know it is
loading is validation level cheerleading
is validation level 7 but the kid gets
more dysregulated I would say if the
kids getting once regulated it's not
experienced as validating even though
cheerleading could consider because
there that that's their go-to and
they're not acknowledging the kids
sentence saying I know I know you feel
like math oh absolutely absolutely if
you may indeed invalidate a moment
absolutely ok I'm going to open it up to
2a next question was a question about
mechanisms of change and I'm wondering
if from the different from the different
orientations we've heard about mental
ization DBT if we look at behavioral
outcome to what extent do we have
evidence that that treating the hyper
mentalizing or mentor reflective
functioning or in dbt that the things
that we think we're doing actually are
mechanisms of change what evidence do we
have evidence of that I can go first I
do think in general intervention
research has suffered from not looking
at the mechanisms have changed
adequately and I would say for the last
five years perhaps there's been a new
interest in there and so in the Oct that
Bateman foggy did in 2008 and adults
they didn't really assess mechanism to
change explicitly in the RCT that treaty
or so and peter fonda he did for the
adolescence they did actually include a
metallization questionnaire I wouldn't
say it was the best one that you could
possibly do but at that time you know so
they started to study in 2009 2010 there
wasn't really much out there but they
did show that it was a reduction in that
mental ization that that was associated
with the reduction in South our behavior
and then borderline symptoms but I think
generally we're correct is that and we
need to include that more in our
research okay and on that note we are
going to say thank you very much dr.
Sharpe we're so glad you are with us
sorry
on the DBT side of things Marsha Linehan
developed a ways of coping checklist
which is a list of kind of skillful ways
of coping with things and I think she's
published a number of papers
demonstrating the effectiveness of some
of these DBT skills on its effect on
emotion dysregulation and improved
outcomes in other areas but as Carla
suggests I think there's a lot more room
for improvement with instrumentation and
better analyses okay and we have a
question here about helping parents with
extinction and and having it not lead to
reinforcing escalations of behavior
during what during what's called a
behavioral burst that they they
mentioned and I and I want to invite
this you know i think i think in
addition to our our treatment experts
you know in terms of suggestions of
getting through the the behavioral burst
if alison has anything to comment on on
not getting respond you know going
through a treatment where you're with
people trying to respond to you when
things come up getting through that
without it leading to kind of worse
behaviors if that makes sense and only
if you're comfortable so again so it's
really about how do you help people get
through when they're not going to
reinforce something not ending up where
you have to reinforce because now it's
gotten completely out of control any
thoughts about that I absolutely this is
something that we have to tell parents
at the very beginning when we discuss
extinction we would discuss ignoring
that in many many cases was going to
happen the behavior that used to be
reinforced and no longer is reinforced
it's going to ask al it because the
child is like what just happened you
know I used to be reinforced with that
by with
whatever would you know getting whatever
I want and all of a sudden none nothing
so I need to do more of it I need to
make you know make it even worse I need
to increase the duration and then parent
needs to be prepared to what to do with
this so you do a lot of coping ahead
with the parent and you have to make
them understand that they need to hold
on for dear life and not reinforce no
matter what otherwise they are member we
talked about term pain and the suffering
so right now then pain then it's going
to be suffering and you need to have
them understand this and you need to
have them cope a hat what they're going
to do if this is to happen the other
thing I tell them that sometimes you
need to make sure that child will be
safe and that your property will be
saved you know what I have parents
removing some of the valuables from the
house and reinforcing doors because they
they have they have to stay you know
behind that door when child is raging
outside I had one parent who was
sleeping on the floor of her other
child's bedroom because she would not
want to come out because the other child
was standing outside and would be no
continuing to scream and yell and mom
could not come out because otherwise you
would reinforce it so a lot of things
that needs to be considered ahead of
time and this is something that you need
to process with the parent and also the
other thing is that I keep telling them
if you're absolutely sure that you
cannot withstand this because of
whatever it is then be prepared that you
know maybe maybe you just need to go
around it in a different way if you have
to go somewhere and you have to be
somewhere and you cannot just ignore
this you need to figure out what to do
with that ahead of time my only two
other sense about that in addition to
helping the parents fortify themselves
they sometimes the spouse of significant
other needs to help the other bite the
bullet soothe self-soothe in the back
room behind a locked door during that is
sometimes you know soothing you know
finding an alternative behavior for the
child and and reinforce some other
behavior and Sue them let them know this
is tough like I know this is hard I know
I'm not giving you what you're asking
for I know this guy so you can kind of
do all that
I don't know if that would fit into her
protocol but in terms of with the
adolescents I work with it's not to say
you have to always blatantly ignore any
just saying I'm not getting this back
I'm going to tell you right now I'm
going to close the door I know it's
going to be hard for you and kind of
validate the kid as you're going through
this extinction burst right we know
parents say no what I answered this
question ones I'm not going to talk
about this anymore and then you know not
just start ignoring all of a sudden and
usually children understand you know
after a couple of those things that you
know what's going on there there's
another question that came in
specifically for Allison Allison would
you care to comment on that before I
move on to this which I move to this
aisle move on to this so first it's a
thank you for sharing for the trust for
your trust and sharing your personal
experience here today and the question
that comes in is if you could comment as
someone who's speaking here to speaking
about your experience of having BPD gone
going through that kind of treatment
whether hearing researchers and
clinicians speak about these issues and
board in Portland personality disorder
feels invalidating or is it a positive
experience interesting validating
anything like that I would say that it's
probably a little bit of both and and it
does it does say a more open do you have
impressions that you're comfortable
sharing about about again being here
hearing the other speakers today I'm
just that I'm really happy to be here
and to learn something from everyone
that presents okay thank you alright we
have a question here we've got more dvt
questions in here this one is about
about situations where you're treating I
the kids perhaps but then there you
observe that there's a BPD and the
parents and we when do you diagnose a
parent when you're treating the child or
any other comments about about this kind
of issue if you haven't identified child
but then there's
you observe a BPD and the parent I don't
know if I would make a diagnosis of the
parent but I certainly would be
comfortable talking about i denti the
fact that we have them in our
multifamily group and they every five or
six weeks we go over the five problem
area that relate knowledge the teenager
but to each parent that their self
endorsing I'm having trouble with my
anchor and having trouble with
relationships and having trouble with my
you know impulses so they're kind of
self disclosing without my prompting
necessarily what they're struggling with
and what help they need and if if
through this multifamily skills group
where their presumably acquiring skills
practicing skills strengthening skill of
generalizing skills if that's not
getting any bang for its buck and we
have some family sessions I might make a
private recommendation to consider their
own personal therapy you know either
during or after that to make sure we
help them you know reach their goals as
relates to look personally as well as it
to their to their children thank you
there are some oh this next one is are
there or could there be DBT trained
crisis call centers or after-hours
coaches and then it goes on for when a
therapist primary coach may not be
available so coaching not by the
therapist certainly in the schools that
were consulting to now you know we have
the I primary clinician if you will but
then it's cool there's special ed
teachers guidance counselors who have
also come to our trainings and they're
serving as kind of milieu coaches so
when the primary therapist is otherwise
occupied and we don't want to interrupt
their sessions because something is of
higher urgency we train the kids to
school kids to go to another one of
their identified DBT team members to get
some coaching as needed so absolutely do
that and certainly there's other
settings to even an outpatient where you
might have somebody on call covering for
them there's some places that around the
country that I know actually rotate call
I don't know if that works as well I
think that's another empirical question
my bias is that if if you're my client
you're more likely to call me as opposed
to some stranger who you don't know but
I'd be open to anybody its thoughts on
the matter because
I don't know if that's necessarily true
and it the question was about anybody
calling specific crisis lines it was
about it was about having are there DBT
trained crisis call centers or after
hours coaches like is their eyes their
availability especially bit possibly
possibly right right um I don't think
it's going to hurt I'm not sure if
coaching can be readily available
because you need in order to coach you
need to first teach and how are you
going to coach somebody who never you
know earn how do you do it so it's not
going to hurt in terms of the crisis
counselor being able to validate and
accept and maybe provide some
suggestions I don't grab a piece of eyes
to pace breathing whatever it may be
whether or not the client will be able
to understand and appreciate and
actually do it that would be a different
question Oh dijo meaning behind it right
there is a specific question about are
there DBT materials printed in Spanish
there are we've translated and back
translated the older version number
adolescent skills manual so my colleague
megan lena ramon did the translation and
we have someone back translated so if
somebody would like a copy of that you
can email me we will get that to you
those are the questions we have I want
to extend a thank you not to our
speakers for generously donating their
time to all of our again to all of our
volunteers all the many people have been
involved my co-directors the various
sponsors and and all the people who have
supported the co providers so thank you
very much thank you civ Thank You Alec
have a wonderful weekend
you